the gunman was an Afghan security guard
who opened fire on the medical staff he
was employed to protect he has been
detained and an investigation is
underway the Afghan health minister
visited the wounded American at the
hospital and afterwards condemned the
attack you know not further they were
not carrying guns they were not wearing
military uniforms they came here under
immense pressure and we're here only to
serve the people of Afghanistan this was
an inhumane and brutal act which will
unfortunately impact our health services
cure Hospital specializes in pediatrics
and obstetrics and is considered one of
Afghanistan's leading healthcare
facilities it's operated by the us-based
Christian nonprofit cure international
the past two months have seen a string
of attacks targeting foreigners in
Afghanistan
last month taliban militants stormed
kabul guesthouse used by roots of peace
a us-based anti-landmine charity it's
believed the intended target was a
Christian run daycare center next door
don't call the latest tally from
Afghanistan's presidential election
confirms the country is headed for a
runoff vote on Thursday the Election
Commission said no candidate had an
outright majority with almost
eighty-three percent of the ballots
counted security will be a huge
challenge for the eventual winner as
international forces pull out of the
country